MATTHEW WILLIAMS: Hi.
I'm Matthew from the
Android Cloud Team.
And I'm going to talk about how
you're apps can efficiently use
platform resources with the
new job scheduler API's.
You lucky devils.
So what are we
doing here exactly?
I mean this is YouTube.
You could be watching video
game replays or fashion tips.
But don't go just yet.
I'm going to show off a
new way to handle execution
of background jobs in a way that
will improve battery life also
developer's lives.
So what background jobs?
Well, there are
different kinds of work
your app needs to get done
that aren't user facing.
Periodically hitting the
network to upload user data
or downloading
config parameters.
These typically don't need
to be reflected immediately--
if at all-- to the user.
For example, think of
a network operation
that would not update the UI.
The types of jobs I'm talking
about are also self-contained.
One way to think
of it is that we're
interested in execution logic
that can be easily refactored.
Another way to think about it
is that sum bundle of parameters
that you need to know
to run your task.
The [? neove ?] user, the
list of rows in your database
that are dirty, or
the list of contacts
that the user has
requested be uploaded.
So why create a new API?
You might wonder
what's our rationale.
And clearly these things have
been possible for as long
as Android has been around.
Well, not quite.
Take network calls
as an example.
These are a strong candidate
for the kinds of work
we're interested in.
Apps usually do them ASAP
to kind of get them out
of the way.
This leads to unnecessary
radio wake ups
where everyone is doing
their own thing haphazardly.
To sell you some more,
let's take a look at home
we might write code to
periodically upload data
but without the job scheduler.
There are roughly two ways
you could have done this.
You could use a handler
and post a delayed message,
if the period was small enough.
But what happens if the
user kills their app,
or if the system does?
At this point, you decide
the AlarmManager is for you,
because at least
you'll be started
when the alarm goes off.
The problem is now that
if the phone turns off,
your alarm is gone.
So you're stuck doing
your own business stunts.
Then what if in execution time,
the network wasn't available?
You'd need to handle
this and try again later.
You have to register
a broadcast receiver
so you'd know when
connectivity came back.
I guess you could try writing
a sync adapter, which kind of
solves a bunch of
these issues for you
and is an excellent
piece of code.
But it's not intended to
be used for scheduling.
Regardless of route, it
would be a mess and difficult
to get right.
So we've decided to
get it wrong for you.
We've taken pre-existing
functionality, wired it
together with new functionality,
and we're giving it to you
in a nice palatable package.
We've introduced the concept
of idle mode, a window of time
for which the system has
determined the phone is unused
and is not likely to
be turned on soon.
For example, having a job
run while the device is idle
and also charging is likely
to happen at night when
the user is sleeping with the
phone plugged in next to them.
The second thing we've
done is integrate
it closely with new system API
so that it will inform clients
when the network is active.
This means that the
handshake with the carrier
has already happened.
So when we batch your app's
network calls to follow on
shortly after, it will
circumvent the battery course
of you doing this
handshake independently.
Less pesky battery
blaming and battery
[INAUDIBLE] for you and
more battery for our users.
So let's take a look at how
to use this functionality.
Here we'll see the sorts of
work you might like to express.
Run this when the
phone is plugged in.
Run this whenever an unmetered
network becomes available.
But make sure I run
within the hour.
Wait at least 10 minutes,
and then run this
the next time the
device is idle.
Every 15 minutes, whenever
a network is available
let me know so I can do
some small health check.
These four use cases there
are a number of constraints.
And you can specify as many
or as few of them as you want.
The scheduler will
only run a job that
has all of its
criteria satisfied.
The one exception being
when you set a deadline.
When this deadline
expires, it'll
override your
existing constraints.
Let's take a look at how
we do this practically.
For this job assessing
the deadline of an hour.
What will happen if the
phone is in airplane mode
after the hour has expired?
Well, we'll talk
about failure retry
in the next and last section.
For now let's look at some
other interesting things.
My job service is the
endpoint you provide.
Here you are identifying
it so that the system will
know where your job should land.
Wi-Fi upload ID is
handled on your job
to differentiate it from
others as you schedule.
So it's your integer
that you pick yourself.
You take this job in
for object, and it
passes into the system in
a normal way, and voila.
But where does my logic go?
OK, so you extend a service
provider by the framework.
The framework service handles
all of the serious life cycle
mechanics for you, leaving you
with only the implementation
of onStartJob and
onStopJob to worry about.
Once your job is
landed on your service
and you've done whatever
it is you set out to do,
call jobFinished
and you're done.
And that's more or less it.
Oh yeah, I mentioned
it was really
easy to request a reschedule
if your job failed
for some reason.
In either onStartJob
or jobFinished,
you provide a
Boolean to indicate
whether you need
to be rescheduled.
Bam!
Done.
OK, that's a lot of detail.
But if you're still
with me, you have it
and are ready to use this stuff.
The take away is that being
good citizen should be
is painless a show as possible.
So thanks for watching.